pierre Lebeau a été témoin de la
destruction du cœur de sa ville il était
le premier photographe arrivé sur les
lieux le soir du déraillement
aujourd'hui il s'habitue encore
difficilement au bâtiment moderne qui
ont été construits au fil des ans dans
le centre-ville toute la chambre il ne
pue moi j'ai comme fête un deuil de
toute la beauté de centre-ville qu'on
avait avant
en disant les bâtiments on peut à peu
pousser sur la rue Frontenac et en
périphérie on y retrouve notamment un
hôtel un centre d'esthétique et quelques
immeubles à logement ce n'est plus comme
avant c'est plus une seule rue qui est
maintenant notre centre ville le
centre-ville est devenu un quartier avec
la rue parallèle la promenade Papineau
en fait où les commerces se sont
installés
l'un des projets collectifs les plus
porteurs le Concerto ici des enfants
s'amusent dans un parc intérieur c'est
aussi un lieu de rencontre pour les
organismes communautaires et des
logements à prix modiques sont offerts à
l'étage les jambes recommence à se
déplacer puis toujours avoir on voit une
vitalité qui se passe ici c'était tout
un défi de repartir à zéro pour la
municipalité la dernière fois qu'une
ville du Québec a été confrontée à une
reconstruction si majeure c'était à
Rimouski en 1950 après un incendie de
grande envergure la qualité relative de
tout ça défi qui a suscité un vif
intérêt des urbanistes comme Gérard
Bodet si le style choisi ne plaît pas
tous il aurait été difficile de
reconstruire le centre-ville comme il
était avant parce que la manière de
capter le territoire plus du tout la
même chose donc l'idée d'avoir des
bâtiments avec des commerces en
rez-de-chaussée des bureaux des
logements à l'étage je pas sûr que ça
aurait pu être absorbé par le marché la
transformation du centre-ville est
encore en marche d'autres projets se
concrétiseront sous peu de nouvelles
salles communautaires un restaurant au
bord du lac il ne reste plus que deux
terrains à vendre selon la mairesse
alors ça se reconstruit au rythme de la
communauté qui se mobilise des
investisseurs qui arrivent des moyens
aussi financiers qu'on est capable de
mettre en place les incitatifs un
processus qui est long selon Girard
baudet notamment en raison de la
situation économique de la ville si on
avait une du croissance économique forte
avec une croissance démographique forte
qui l'aurait accompagné mais il y aura
eu un marché pour accélérer le processus
de reconstruction mais c'est pas le cas
puis je continue d'aimer négatif comme
la première fois que je l'ai vu pierre
Lebeau a toutefois de la difficulté à ne
pas être nostalgique du dynamisme de
l'époque lorsqu'il regarde des photos du
centre-ville d'avant la tragédie avant
son Frontenac
tu avais des commerces avec des
logements où tués le soir les gens
sortaient après dîner promener le petit
enfant à aller se promener en couple ça
vivait ici quand la promenade Papineau à
5h 6h c'est fermé là c'est mort la
mairesse croit quant à elle que ce n'est
qu'une question de temps pour que les
citoyens se réapproprient pleinement les
lieux on a perdu tout le patrimoine bâti
et culturel s'assurerait pas ça c'est
les générations qu'ils créent c'est
c'est l'histoire qui finit par amener de
l'arbre au bâtiment au lieu donc ça va
prendre peut-être quelques quelques
générations ici Thomas